[Musique]
moi
on
la honte et le premier four du
fonctionnement du drive donc les
rendez-vous en a pris
une trentaine aujourd'hui mais quand on
fonctionnera à plein régime ce sera aux
aventures de 60 80 par jour
[Musique]
ça s'adresse au personnel soignant mais
également à tous les toutes les
personnes qui sont dans les indications
c'est à dire les patients à risque qui
sont symptomatiques les femmes enceintes
soixante dix ans tous les personnes qui
sont concernées par les indications est
définie par la yaris
[Musique]
non
nous sommes en train de doubler notre
capacité de tests par pcr
je voulais déjà dit ce qui nous permet
de lancer une vaste opération de
dépistage des personnes les plus
vulnérables en mettant la priorité sur
les personnes âgées les personnes
handicapées les plus fragiles ainsi que
les professionnels qui les accompagnent
en établissement comme à domicile
[Musique]
ans